- [Instructor] I wanna talk
a little bit about carbon
and how it cycles through our biosphere.
And we touch on this in other videos.
But when we talk about
elements like carbon,
they don't just appear and disappear
all of a sudden in our biosphere.
For the most part, they have
been here since the beginning.
But they just get recycled
from one form to another.
And that is also true of carbon.
And to appreciate carbon's importance
in our biosphere, and especially to life,
I have some, some important molecules,
or examples of important
molecules that involve carbon.
In all of these, the carbons
are these dark gray colors.
So this right over here,
this molecule,
this is glucose.
Glucose, simple sugar.
It's where we can derive
a lot of our energy from.
This is ATP, you can view it as
a more immediate store of
energy in biological systems.
This right over here is
one of many amino acids.
The amino acids make up our proteins.
This right over here is DNA.
And in all of these you can see
the role that carbon is playing.
In fact, sometimes the
carbon's hard to see
because it's closer to the
center of these molecules
because the carbon, for the most part,
forms the backbone.
Because carbon's this really
neat, this really neat element,
this really neat atom
that can make four bonds.
It can make these really
really really cool structures.
But the question is how does carbon cycle
through our biosphere?
And we can get as simple or as complex
as we want to when we discuss this.
But on very very simple terms,
this is how my brain tends to
think about the carbon cycle.
You can imagine the
carbon in our atmosphere
that's mainly in the form
of molecular carbon dioxide.
So this right over here,
this is CO two.
Once again, the carbon
is in the middle there,
bonded to the two oxygens.
And as much as we talk about CO two,
and as important as carbon
is to living systems.
In fact, our bodies are 18
to 19 percent carbon
carbon by mass.
So it's very important
for biological systems.
As important as carbon
is to biological systems,
and the role carbon dioxide plays
in things like global
warming, it actually makes up
a very small percentage of our atmosphere.
It's only about 0.04 percent
of the gas in our atmosphere.
Most of our atmosphere
is actually nitrogen,
78 percent, you don't talk a lot about it.
And oxygen, 21 percent.
And then a bunch of other,
a bunch of other elements and molecules.
But the very simple
version of the carbon cycle
is, okay, you have this
atmospheric carbon dioxide,
molecular carbon dioxide,
hanging out in the air.
And you have autotrophs like plants.
So let's say this is the ground,
and I have a growing plant.
So that's a plant right over there.
That's its leaf, that's another leaf.
And the way that plants grow
is they're able to take light energy.
So that's energy coming in from the sun,
and use that energy to fix carbon.
Now fixing carbon sounds
like a very fancy thing,
but it's literally taking
that molecular carbon dioxide
out of the air and
fixing the carbon from it
to form these different
molecules in the plant,
that help the plant, that
give the plant structure,
that give the plant energy.
And so that mass of that plant,
I'm actually in this room
I'm in, there's a houseplant
right next to me, it's
not just growing out of,
I mean, I guess you could say
it's growing out of thin air,
but the mass isn't just
magically appearing.
It's taking that mass out of the air.
And so that's where,
so that's what allows this
plant to keep growing.
And so, once again, as I said,
some of that will be in
the form of proteins,
amino acids, it could form
structural components.
It could be fats,
and also some of it is energy.
And you could imagine other animals
that can't do this, that
can't photosynthesize,
well, they might wanna eat these plants
for that energy.
In other videos, we talk
about the food cycle.
And so, this could be me.
This could be me having a salad,
and I might want to eat that plant.
I might wanna eat the
plant for the sugar in it.
Maybe it's an apple of some kind,
and then that gives my body
the energy to live and grow.
And as I, as I metabolize that glucose,
so for example glucose
is one of the molecules
that that plant can form
by taking that carbon out of the air.
And then I might metabolize that glucose
from that plant I just ate,
and as I do that, I will
release carbon dioxide.
So I will release the CO two
back in the air.
And then you can see that
you can form a cycle here.
The CO two gets released by
things that are metabolizing
these organic molecules, and
then it can get fixed again
by autotrophs, which are
able to store the energy
from the sun with, in
terms of these bonds,
by fixing this carbon.
But there's other
pathways that we can have
to have these cycles.
For example, some of the CO
two, it could be absorbed
into the ocean.
It could be absorbed into,
And in the ocean it can form carbonate,
and so once again you still see
the carbon right over there,
carbon bonded to three oxygens,
and calcium carbonate is a key constituent
in things like seashells.
And over time, as the
sea shells break down,
and they get ground up,
and they get impacted
with pressure, they can form,
they can form limestone.
So this right over here is limestone.
Limestone.
But once again, it was
formed from carbon dioxide
being absorbed into the ocean,
living things using that calcium,
using that calcium carbonate,
the carbonate in conjunction with calcium,
in order to form these
shells, which get ground down,
and it actually forms
these rock structures.
You can have situations,
you can have situations
where living things,
whether we're talking about
the autotrophs like plants,
or we're talking about things
like me that are eating
the plants, well, once they
die and there's all this
organic matter that hasn't
been broken down yet.
Well, it gets buried in the ground.
I'll do the plant because it's less morbid
than showing me dead.
So let's say this is the plant.
Well, with enough pressure and time.
Sometimes in the decomposing process,
some of the carbon might be released.
But over time this might be compressed
and be turned into fossil fuels.
So when you see oil or when
you are burning gasoline,
which is really just a
refined part of the oil,
it is really this organic matter
that was, that's storing energy
that plants were able to
store from light energy,
possibly millions or tens
of millions of years ago.
But then if you were to take that same,
if you were to take that
fossil fuel out of the ground,
which we now do very actively
in order to power all of the
things that we need to power,
and you were to burn it.
So let me see, if I were to.
Let me just draw an example of that.
So let's say you just had,
if you had a canister of oil.
I'm not gonna do the oil in black
because you'd have trouble seeing it.
And if you were to burn it.
If you were to burn it,
the process of,
the process of combustion.
And this is in general, if
you're burning anything,
it doesn't just have to be oil.
It could be burning a piece of wood.
You're taking that organic matter,
those carbon-carbon bonds,
and in some ways you can say you're doing
the reverse of the photosynthesis process.
You're breaking it down,
and in that process,
you're releasing that carbon,
and it's getting released
in the form of
carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide, which in theory
could then be fixed once again.
So the general idea,
autotrophs like plants,
when they photosynthesize,
they can fix that carbon.
And then it could either be burnt,
and a combustion process can release
that carbon back into the atmosphere,
or you could have other
animals eating that plant.
And then, as they
metabolize, as they break
these carbon-carbon
bonds to power themselves
or just do whatever they need to do,
that also can release carbon dioxide.